saving lives when you're a medical
professional or first responder makes
sense but how about when you're an
ordinary civilian we're about to watch
some serious life-saving videos let's
get started be whoop
what was he what was the reaction what
was the trigger she's had she's not
allergic to anything that's known she's
had some salmon have you touched
anything I don't know okay see the way
that she's talking right away we have to
know that her Airway is closing so you
have to act quickly there is no use
trying to figure out what this person is
allergic to the only important thing is
to recognize the ABCs of First Response
and in this case the airway is being
compromised so you have to act quickly
with that epinephrine AKA and
epinephrine auto injector like an EpiPen
that's it the tongue is swelling you
gotta make moves you have to act quickly
this is like when I was on the plane in
the pilot like do we have an hour and a
half to go back to Canada or an hour to
go to the Portugal Islands no we don't
so we'll go half a milligram of
adrenaline so beautiful please uh
eventually some hydrocortisone as well
all right so they're also giving her
some steroid here as well steroid
reduces inflammation but the first thing
you want to do is get that epinephrine
on board that's what's going to open up
the airway that's what's going to
actually constrict the blood vessels to
increase blood pressure because part of
an anaphylactic attack is not just your
throat closing is blood pressure
drastically dropping so tell me what
you're having through that nebulizer is
what we give to asthmatic patients to
open the airway okay remember patients
who are experiencing anaphylactic attack
feel very uncomfortable because you can
experience gastrointestinal distress
vomiting low blood pressure and then
when you get the the EpiPen you're still
not out of the woods you're still very
uncomfortable and your heart it's
raising now you got a dose of adrenaline
sorry
oh sorry
all right in a lot of situations like
this as well it's very important to have
a good line of communication with the
patient because what they may be
experiencing or thinking that they're
experiencing is not what they're
actually experiencing I'll give you an
example when I was on the plane after
the first dose of epinephrine the
gentleman who who was experiencing the
anaphylactic attack told me he thinks
it's coming back but after I uh directly
observed his throat with my iPhone
flashlight this is the tools I'm using
there I actually saw that his throat was
just getting very dry because I gave him
a big dose of adrenaline which is one of
the side effects so his throat wasn't
actually closing up again so it's
important to directly visualize these
things as well as talk to the patient
are you feeling any better
a little bit a little bit good Okay so
we've done something right then see
using humor to diffuse the situation
here is really powerful he's not making
her uh the target of the joke they're
both together making light of the
situation in order to decrease that
stress anything you can do to take away
that anxiety will help the patient
doctors still don't know what cause her
allergic reaction you know in a lot of
cases we don't know that's why allergy
testing along with a thorough history is
really important here there's even very
unique situations where if you get a
certain type of tick bite a lone star
tick bite you could actually end up
developing an allergy to red meat that
you've never had in your life which is
what happened on the gentleman in the
airplane that I was uh fortunate enough
to be on at the time to save his life 35
year old mom Tila Levy turns away for
just a moment 11 month old Eton on the
changing table on an elevated surface
and in the presence of water like in a
bath you do not leave your children
unattended no matter how quick you think
it is even with dogs I would put in in
with dogs as well the baby begins to
roll every parent's fear and then he
tumbles over the edge out of nowhere his
older brother nine-year-old Joseph
catches him wow what a car honestly they
gotta stop doing SportsCenter Top 10 for
a week and just show this kid making a
catch I just yelled mom because I saw
the baby and I just ran and I caught him
Yankees signed this kid now I can't even
carry him so I don't know how that
happened and I can't even run that fast
either that's super superhuman it goes
without saying babies falling very
dangerous because they're developing
still their organs so very susceptible
to injuries and drops remember babies
bones are also soft especially their
skulls so their their brain is not as
well protected as an adult skull okay we
have a child drinking water drinking
water
drinking a lot of water
choking anytime you see someone reach
for their throat like that and is trying
to talk but can't move air that's a sign
that someone's choking in scenarios like
this for a child of this age you would
treat them just like an adult not an
infant and you would start the Heimlich
maneuver some agencies do talk about
doing five back taps with the person
bent over the arm and then start the
Heimlich maneuver you're going to be
squeezing as hard as you can and you're
going to do that five times go back to
the back blows until you free whatever
the obstruction is don't do this blind
finger sweeping thing because that can
actually push the object further down
instead what you want to do is try and
visualize if you can see whatever it is
that's out in the mouth and then pull it
out
see that's a child saying they're
choking right there oh we got the
Heimlich maneuver perfect good execution
wow got it out
[Music]
wow Brock and body shop were being
typical two-year-old twins scrambling up
their dresser to explore but then
suddenly it tips over pinning little
Brock under its heavy weight you can see
Brock struggling and screaming but Bodhi
jumps right into action he immediately
tries to push the dresser but can't get
it to move finally with a billion he
tries to push one more time and somehow
manages the strength to move that large
dresser and free his brothers that's why
with a lot of furniture items like that
you really should be securing them to
the wall in fact a lot of them do say
that you should secure them to the wall
in their instructions and that doesn't
just go for a Furniture like that but
also for like heavy mirrors as well too
Mom says as soon as she saw that video
she bolted the dresser to the wall to
make sure it won't happen again
oh what is that this five-year-old girl
had her own scary encounter with a wild
animal a raccoon latched onto her leg
wouldn't let go oh raccoons problematic
being mammals they can be exposed to
rabies and therefore transmit rabies I
grabbed it by the Scruff of the neck it
was growling it was snarling
a lot of times we'll think that a
raccoon is rabid when it's starting to
come out during the day exhibiting on
characteristic behaviors like going up
to people because they usually don't do
this they kind of run away more often
out of an abundance of caution mom and
daughter have gotten rabies shots if
you've been exposed to rabies or even
you think there's a possibility you've
been exposed to rabies generally what we
do is something called post-exposure
prophylaxis which means something like
15 minutes of washing the wound then
getting the rabies vaccines on specific
set days and then in definite confirmed
cases and and severely endemic areas you
want to be using immunoglobulins or
monoclonal antibodies it's a family
crisis that's unfolding in real time but
the little guy's parents John and Jane
Kohler quickly realize this is serious
he was turning blue cyanosis or turning
blue is one of the dangerous signs that
not enough oxygen is moving and with
babies you want to act fairly quickly
but at the same time stay calm and
deliver those same back blows that we
just talked about the back thrust but
with a base maybe you want to hold them
down so their head is lower than their
body by doing this you're actually
allowing gravity to help you free the
obstruction and then you do the same
back thrusts now if that fails then you
do the opposite you flip them to the
opposite side now on their back head is
still below and then you're going to be
doing the Heimlich maneuver with them
laying on your arm you don't want to do
a full heimlich maneuver on a child less
than one year of age because you can
cause damage to their developing organs
pan corrupts
all right so again the mom is in a very
stressful situation the goal here is to
say you call 9-1-1 not someone because
then everyone else assumes that someone
is going to call 9-1-1 and no one ends
up calling 9-1-1 major Hillard had a
device in his car called a life back
which he suctioned to little Gabriel's
mouth after several plunges of the
device a miracle as soon as I did that
last pull his eyes popped open and he
started gasping for air
yeah
Mom and Dad Embrace in relief so it's
interesting this life back and other
devices like it I've kind of been going
viral on social media that the Joker is
one that I saw as well the major
organizations like uh the ones that do
first aid have not sort of started
recommending them because there hasn't
been good quality rigorous trials to
show that they're more effective than
traditional back blows and the Heimlich
maneuver in situations like this the all
the major organizations are still saying
use the traditional methods I I'm
curious when the government or some
agency is actually going to put money in
this to make sure that we can find out
if these devices actually work because
if they do we should have these devices
at every restaurant in 2019 this
friendly pickup hockey game suddenly
turned when one of the players collapsed
from a massive heart attack oh wow
all right call 9-1-1 good first step you
gotta nominate someone a player from the
opposing team then took charge as luck
would have it he was an emergency room
physician
yep the defibrillator is very important
here the defibrillators we have in most
of these scenarios are automatic
defibrillators where you just attach
them to the chest and uh they will
automatically read the Rhythm and tell
you if this is a shockable situation or
not Shock advised charging stay clear of
patient we administered that shock and
administered a little bit more CPR for
another minute and a half and it started
breathing on his own that's spontaneous
return of circulation that's really
exciting I mean if you're going to have
a cardiac arrest having one around an ER
physician is the person you want to be
around the sad part about Cardiac Arrest
is that the majority of them happen
outside of the hospital and as a result
there's not enough people trained in CPR
or know how to perform CPR this is why
I'm working with the American Heart
Association to get these kiosks put all
across the U.S and Airport science
museums where you actually learn how to
perform hands-only CPR with me on the
screen check this out it may have been
the whole crew behind this nearly
impossible mission back in 2009 but it
was Jason Oglesby who dangled from a
crane and pulled Patty Ralph mealy to
safety her boat had capsized along the
Des Moines River her husband died she
was saved you know it's very possible
that you may be an individual who finds
someone who's recently drowned and
they're unconscious in those situations
you want to start chest compressions
right away it's ideal actually and a lot
of agencies do advise to do two rescue
breaths before starting the chest
compressions in a drowning victim
scenario remember in most cases you're
actually not going to have that much
water go into the lungs the larynx can
actually spasm preventing a lot of water
from entering the lungs and the small
amount that could have gone into the
lungs can actually get absorbed into the
bloodstream so it's really about getting
that heart to pump and it's pumping
artificially because you're physically
pumping it and circulating the blood
that's actually still potentially having
some oxygen in it and obviously calling
for help is the number one thing you do
little Mason Lindemann was playing in
his driveway with Friends when the pit
bull escaped from a neighbor's home and
attacked clapping his jaw down on the
boy's head that's so dangerous so much
bleeding can happen so much
disfigurement suddenly a hero comes to
the rescue the teen who heard the boy
screams runs right into the path of
danger watches he deliberately diverts
the pit bull's attention now the dog
goes after him giving the six-year-old
kid a chance to run home wow the hero
neighbor is also attacked when he loses
his sneaker and falls to the ground in a
situation like this you gotta roll up
into a ball protect your vital organs
remember if you get bitten in the
carotids if you get uh bitten into the
stomach that's where a lot of bleeding
is going to happen but if you roll up
into a ball and most importantly make
fists so that your fingers can't get
ripped off you decrease the likelihood
of very severe injury if you are
witnessing someone through this the
common thing that's taught is the
wheelbarrow technique where you lift up
the dog's back legs it's used more to
break up dog fights between dogs not
dogs attacking humans but that could be
done as well making loud noises shooting
water all these things are options just
make sure you don't put yourself in
danger and never put your hands or
fingers in between two dogs that are
fighting or a dog that's attacking
someone else because what's going to
happen is your fingers are going to get
very very damaged and that's dangerous
afterwards for a child like this you
want to make sure that they're okay from
a psychological perspective a
circulatory perspective and that they're
getting antibiotics tetanus and
potentially rabies depending on what you
know about this dog he's got a bruise
under here still wow and he's got a
small scratch there he also has Staples
in the back of his head Staples are very
common to be used in the scalp scalp has
a lot of bleeding as well because it's
highly vascular so folks get very afraid
but usually that area heals quite well
I'm glad you're okay
Grant suffered bite injuries to his hand
while fighting off the pit bull the dog
was right on top of me so I tried to
grab his throat and it bit me that's why
you gotta right away curl up into a ball
or punches fingers close because
otherwise you will get bit The 28 year
old woman seen Friday in the
surveillance video inside the lobby of
the DeLand Animal Hospital says after
two days of being assaulted by her
boyfriend 39 year old Jeremy Floyd she
convinced him to bring her dog to the
vet then this note handed off to the vet
staff saying her boyfriend was
threatening her with a gun I slept with
a note and that's when I slid my glasses
off to show her I had a bruise either so
she would take me seriously first of all
you have to give credit to the Survivor
of this ipv and I go past calling it
domestic violence because it's really
intimate partner violence we've sort of
changed the way we refer to these things
because domestic means you live in the
home and that could be a parent a
grandparent intimate partner is someone
you could just go on a date with and
violence doesn't just mean physical
violence it could be verbal violence as
well then she saw an officer through the
window first a sigh of relief officers
safely taking Floyd in his loaded
handgun into custody the victim thankful
the employees got her the help she
needed this is her terrible situations
and so many factors go into them just
even a patient sharing that with you is
really powerful and there's evidence to
show that thanking a patient for sharing
that with you goes a really long way the
way that I've sort of been trained to
think about this is an approach of
empathy validation and then assistance
you want to be as empathetic as possible
you want to be understanding as possible
then validating that the patient doesn't
deserve this that this isn't uh their
fault because a lot of times they've not
necessarily been brainwashed but been
misled to believe that this is happening
to them and it's their fault it's their
problem and then finally offering
assistance not forcing assistance
because that can backfire for a whole
host of reasons and as medical providers
we're also trained that if somehow the
abuser is in the office in the exam room
Etc it's best not to confront them and
let the patient guide the situation
unless there's imminent danger of course
in that case you're calling local
authorities it's really all about making
sure the patient has resources and
safety and a plan of action if they feel
their life is truly in danger and if you
yourself are a victim of ipv I have
links and resources down below to get
yourself help
check out this video where patient
actually filed a complaint against me I
think it's worth watching because it's a
good learning experience and as always
stay happy and healthy
foreign
[Music]